[Music]
foreign
welcome back so we're talking about
second order linear ordinary
differential equations we have shown how
to solve these a number of ways and now
I'm just going to give you a bunch of
examples and we're going to work through
them to build some real intuition for
for these problems
so the first one I'm going to do is uh X
double dot Plus
3x Dot
plus 2X
equals zero and if you like you can kind
of pretend that this came from a you
know spring Mass damper system with you
know Mass one spring constant two and
damping coefficient three whatever you
like it doesn't really matter okay this
is a second order linear differential
equation and we're going to solve this a
couple of ways and then I'm also going
to plot the solution in Matlab or python
and so in addition to
um having this differential equation we
also need its initial conditions to
uniquely specify the solution and so
we're going to say that we have X at
time 0 equals two
and x dot at time 0 equals I think I
want to say that this is minus three
I solve this problem ahead of time this
is the kind of problem I would give on
like a midterm or an exam or a homework
because all of the coefficients are
integers and everything's going to work
out nicely it doesn't have to be that
way but that's kind of how I've uh how
I've chosen this so these are my initial
conditions here okay and this is a
pretty easy setup now we know how to
solve these systems we know how to work
with these so I'm just going to do it
um
the basic idea here is that we are going
to guess the solution we're going to try
X of T equals e to the Lambda t
and we're going because we know that e
to the Lambda T is kind of the base the
base solution of all linear ordinary
differential equations or at least we're
starting to suspect that that might be
the case and that is because when I take
the derivative x dot of T I get a
constant Lambda times my original
function e to the Lambda T so my
derivative is just a constant times x my
second derivative X double dot of T is
just Lambda squared e to the Lambda T
which is just another constant times x
of T times e to the Lambda T and so any
amount of derivatives I take of this e
to the Lambda T I'm going to get a
constant times e to the Lambda T which
means that if I plug all of these into
my differential equation I'm going to
get kind of a polynomial in Lambda times
e to the Lambda T so let's do that right
now so we're going to plug this into our
ode
maybe I'll switch colors uh like green
right now
and so I'm just going to literally plug
X double dot in here and x dot in here
and X in here and we're going to equate
all of the terms so I'm going to get a
Lambda squared
e to the Lambda T that's my X double dot
plus 3x dot is 3 Lambda e to the Lambda
t plus 2X that's plus 2 e to the Lambda
T and all of that equals zero all of
that equals zero
and so again we've done this before I'm
going to do this a bunch of times and in
the next lecture I'm going to show you
what happens when you have higher order
differential equations with more
derivatives x triple dots X quadruple
dots and things like that and nothing's
going to change essentially so every
single term has an e to the Lambda T
because all of my derivatives have an e
to the Lambda T and so I can factor that
out and so I get just my stuff with
Lambda is Lambda squared
plus 3 Lambda plus two
times e to the Lambda T equals zero now
e to the Lambda T essentially never
equals zero except when Lambda T is
negative Infinity so this is basically
not going to happen so the only way that
this expression can equal zero for all
time is if this polynomial in Lambda
equals zero and this is called the
characteristic polynomial the
characteristic
uh polynomial
and specifically sometimes we call it uh
Char of Lambda okay let's find the
characteristic polynomial but
essentially it is that Lambda squared
plus three Lambda plus two equals zero
okay those are the specific lambdas so
we those are the specific lambdas
that so that for those lambdas that
satisfy this characteristic polynomial
then e to the Lambda T will satisfy this
differential equation okay so I plugged
in this e to the Lambda T and all of its
derivatives into this differential
equation and I found this condition that
has to be true for that Lambda for this
equality to hold with these coefficients
so so the Lambda that satisfies this is
the Lambda that will work in this
solution
and now you're starting to see that I
chose these coefficients to be as easy
as possible so you can just Factor this
polynomial you say well maybe I'll
switch colors again maybe I'm feeling
Orange right now okay so I've got uh
something like Lambda plus two
times Lambda plus one that if I multiply
this out I get Lambda squared plus 2
Lambda plus Lambda is plus 3 Lambda so
Lambda squared plus 3 Lambda plus two
okay so that is my characteristic
polynomial
equals zero
and this implies of course that
uh Lambda equals negative two and Lambda
equals negative one are solutions
okay those are two solutions to this
characteristic polynomial lambd equals
negative one we'll solve this and Lambda
equals negative two we'll solve this
let's just verify negative 1 squared is
one
uh minus 3 is negative 2 plus 2 is 0.
good this solves it let's try negative
two negative two squared is four minus
six so four minus six is negative two
plus two is zero so this also solves it
both of these lambdas solve my
characteristic equation and so if I took
e to the Lambda t for either of these
lambdas it's going to satisfy this
differential equation okay in fact that
might not be a terrible thing to show
um so I'll write down my solution my
solution is going to be X of t
equals and it's going to be some
combination of these two e to the Lambda
T's I have an e to the
um
yeah let's call this Lambda 1 and Lambda
2. this is going to be some constant C1
times e to the Lambda 1 t
plus another constant e to the Lambda 2
T and we're going to determine these
constants from my initial conditions so
specifically
um
Lambda 1 is negative 1 I'm just
literally going to write this out this
is C1 e to the minus t
plus C2 e to the minus 2 T and from my
initial data I know
that X at times zero equals two so if I
plug in 0 for time e to the 0 is 1 e to
the zero is one and so I get you know X
at times zero equals C1 plus C2 and that
has to equal the constant two
similarly I can compute x dot
uh and x dot is going to be
minus C1 e to the minus t minus two c
two e to the minus two t
and so x dot at 0 is minus C1 minus two
c two and that has to equal minus three
okay now again I chose these
coefficients to be like trivially easy
you can almost read off just from seeing
it that if C1 equals one and C2 equals
one one plus one equals two
and minus 1 minus 2 is minus three so
these coefficients you can just kind of
read off uh C1 equals C2 equals one
would in fact satisfy both of these
initial conditions if you like you can
solve this a little bit more
methodologically you can write down the
system and you would say Okay C1 plus C2
equals two
as this equation and minus C1 minus 2 c
2 equals minus three and then I would go
through my linear algebra of kind of
solving for C1 or solving for C2 I think
what I would do is I would add these
together
um and I would get something like you
know the C ones cancel and I get minus
C2 equals minus 1 which of course
implies C2 equals plus one
equals plus one and then if C2 equals
one then C1 has to equal one and we're
done one and done okay so kind of easy
to solve for these initial conditions to
solve for these coefficients with these
initial data we get that C1 equals C2
equals one and so literally I can just
I'm just going to erase this and write
down the actual solution
of my differential equation is X of t
equals C1 was one so e to the minus t c
two is also 1 plus e to the minus 2 t
that's the solution of my differential
equation Okay so so really easy we
guessed exponentials we computed their
derivatives plugged them in and found
this characteristic polynomial in Lambda
that had to equal zero this had to be
true for that Lambda to be a solution of
this differential equation okay and then
we uh we found that Lambda could be
minus one or minus two I'm going to call
these eigenvalues because in my mind
their eigenvalues of another system I'll
show you in a minute and then when you
plug these in
here you can solve for the coefficients
any linear combination of e to the minus
t and e to the minus two t will work you
know Lambda equals negative 1 or
negative two any combination of those
will be a solution of this differential
equation
but only a very specific constant one
and constant two will satisfy this
initial data so we solve for that down
here and this is the specific solution
that satisfies this differential
equation with these initial conditions
good okay okay easy uh easy to do
so
um maybe one thing I will do is you know
like it's pretty easy to verify that
this e to the minus t actually satisfies
this I'll just do that really really
quickly because I said I would so you
know if I took um
e to the minus t that's e to the Lambda
1 t
let's say that's one of my Solutions I'm
just going to verify that if I take its
derivative twice so x dot equals minus E
to the minus t and X double dot equals
minus minus is plus e to the minus t and
if I plug these into my differential
equation here I get you know e to the
minus t plus three negatives minus 3 e
to the minus t plus two positives plus
two e to the minus t yes in fact equals
zero because I have one minus three plus
two that's zero e to the minus t is
equal to zero so I'm just confirming
that yes this e to the Lambda T does
satisfy this equation specifically
because that Lambda satisfied this
characteristic polynomial good okay I'm
actually ready to plot this um so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to erase
this stuff
um we might derive one more equation and
then I'm going to plot the solution of
this differential equation so stay put
okay so I just erased some stuff and
move some stuff around so I have some
place to work this was the solution of
this differential equation for these
initial conditions we had these two
lambdas we guessed a solution e to the
Lambda T and these are the two lambdas
that worked Lambda minus one and Lambda
minus two which were satisfy our
characteristic polynomial in Lambda okay
and again I'm going to show you that we
can also write this as a matrix system
of differential equations because in
Matlab or python we might solve it using
that Matrix system and I'm going to look
at the eigenvalues of that so just very
quickly maybe I'll do this in green
again
I have that um for this equation I can
always write uh instead of just in terms
of second derivatives of X I can
introduce a new variable X and V
and D DT of that state is now going to
be a system of first order differential
equations in X and V this is only first
order because I only have a single
derivative
and specifically we're going to say
um
that x dot equals V so
um
so this is 0 1 on the first row x dot
equals V
and the second row is going to be V Dot
V Dot is X double dot if x dot equals V
then V Dot is X double dot and it's all
of this stuff if I move it over to the
right so minus 2x minus 3x dot so minus
2x minus 3 x dot which is V okay and so
this system of equations is equivalent
to this uh this single
second order ode in a single variable is
equivalent to this system of two first
order Odes in X and V and you can always
do this you can always go kind of back
and forth if I had a fifth derivative I
could write this as a system of five
coupled first order equations by adding
a state for every derivative I've added
the state V my video is done processing
that's great
um I've added a state V for x dot and so
on and so forth okay and this is going
to be my a matrix
my a matrix and specifically the
eigenvalues of this a matrix are in fact
the solutions of my characteristic
polynomials okay so I'll um in fact I
should just show you that right now
maybe I'll just do that
um before I go to Matlab and python
what I'm going to show you is in fact
the eigenvalues of this a matrix are the
solutions of my characteristic
polynomial so I'm going to have a whole
set of lectures on eigenvalues and
eigenvectors so don't uh freak out if
you don't remember what I'm about to
write down but if I want to compute the
eigenvalues of a I literally take the
determinant
of a minus Lambda times the identity
Matrix and I set that equal to zero
and so a minus the identity Matrix times
Lambda is a
minus 2 minus 3.
minus Lambda times the identity Matrix
is just a diagonal matrix with lambdas
this equals minus Lambda 1 minus 2
minus 3 minus Lambda
and now I take the determinant of this
and the determinant of a two by two is
pretty simple it's the product of the
diagonals minus the product of the Cross
off diagonals and so the determinant of
a minus Lambda I
is this thing which is Lambda squared
Plus
3 Lambda
minus minus 2 because you subtract the
product of the off diagonal so minus the
product is two so plus 2 and that whole
thing has to equal zero
and hey would you look at that this
equation for the eigenvalues Lambda
lambdas are now the eigenvalues of this
a matrix this is exactly my
characteristic polynomial so the
eigenvalues of a will satisfy my
characteristic polynomial and the
solutions of my characteristic
polynomial are eigenvalues of a very
very useful very very important property
okay I'm going to again have a whole
lecture showing all about this probably
multiple lectures I just wanted to show
you this here and now I'll get back to
plotting real quick
okay so um yeah this was just showing
the IGS of a the eigenvalues of a are in
fact Solutions in my characteristic
polynomial so they're going to be Lambda
equals minus one and Lambda equals minus
two those are going to be eigenvalues of
this a matrix okay so deep deep
connections between eigenvalues and the
solutions of my linear ordinary
differential equations in fact that's
how I think of eigenvalues if if you you
know Corner me and ask me what's an
eigenvalue I'm going to say well when
you have a system of linear differential
equations the eigenvalues are you know
tell you what the solutions of that
system are going to be
good
um so I think what I want to do now is
just code up this example and show you
kind of plot some stuff and convince you
that these eggs are the same so first
thing I'm going to do um clear all close
all CLC
and maybe what I'm going to do here is
just create my a matrix so a equals 0 1
semicolon minus two minus three okay
that's my a matrix
let's see if it runs okay this is uh a
that's my a matrix and now if I look at
the IGS of a these had better B minus
two and minus one excellent okay so we
have confirmed that the eigenvalues of
this a matrix are in fact the solutions
of my characteristic polynomial which
are going to be the lambdas that work
for the solution of this of this this
differential equation good so that's a
huge check right there in fact that's
probably the biggest thing I wanted to
show you is that that's true and now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
actually plot this analytic solution we
solve this by hand so it's analytic
that's what that means and then I'm
going to numerically integrate this
differential equation using the built-in
kind of you know Small Time step
integrator in Matlab and I'm going to
show you that those plots almost
perfectly match each other okay
so
um I'm going to create a Time Vector
from zero in increments of 0.01 to 10 so
this just means that this is a vector of
time from 0 to time 10 with time steps
of 0.01
and I'm going to start with an initial
condition of 2 semicolon minus three
that's what I had here x
naught is 2 V naught is minus three so
I'm just creating this big initial
condition Vector of X naught and V
naught two and minus 3.
um and I think first I'm just going to
plot x equals the exponential minus t
plus the exponential of minus 2T that is
like my analytic solution here
and we're going to plot T versus X
um
maybe I'll make it a little bigger
because this is a small font lined with
two to make it a little bigger and I'll
just plot that for now
okay something doesn't like
e to the minus two plot
uh I probably just
type something badly let's see
oh you can't do two t it's 2 times T of
course okay good
um
and maybe I'll make my font uh set GCA
font size 24.
okay and so this is my plot I should
probably put axes on I would I would get
upset if my students didn't so this
would be time on the x-axis and this is
the position X on the y-axis
um
good so that's
um you know that's my my X label time
and you know maybe I'll just do that so
I think this is good for you to see X
label
uh it would be time
and why label would be my solution X
okay
good okay good so time and my solution X
and as you expect this thing
exponentially decays this is what we
solved for this is what we find here and
this is the solution plot
so now what I'm going to show you is we
can also numerically integrate this ode
why would we want to do that well you
know we can solve this by hand no
problem it was easy but if I added some
non-linearity or I made this a little
nastier we wouldn't be able to solve it
by hand anymore and so we'd have to
integrate it numerically by taking
little time steps and approximating you
know how X evolves in time and so it's
nice to just be able to do that pretty
pretty easily and so I'm of course going
to write this
as a big Matrix system of equations I'm
going to say that this is uh I'm going
to say that this whole state here this
Vector of X and V is this bold Y and I'm
going to say that bold y if I take D DT
of bold y that equals a
times bold y okay that's that's fine
this is a vector y this is a vector y
this is a matrix this works this is a
matrix system of differential equations
and so there's a built-in integrator
called ode45 which basically will
integrate I'll just write down the
syntax and then explain it to you od45
is a built-in very accurate integrator
built on a runga cut a a fourth order
runga time stepper with an Adaptive time
step so it'll make its delta T smaller
or bigger depending on how accurate the
solution is oh I'm going to have a whole
lecture on this so don't worry about it
ode45
um
and od485 expects these three arguments
this is very similar in Python that I'll
show you in a minute so it expects the
right hand side so D DT of y equals what
what's on the right hand side ode
function is the stuff on the right hand
side it expects a time span that's you
know 0.01 to 10 and it expects an
initial condition why not
create this function that it's expecting
this right hand side I'm literally going
to uh in Matlab the way you do this is
you say at
T comma y this creates a function on the
Fly that has arguments T and Y and that
function is going to be a times y
so that's literally I have just defined
right here a little function that it
returns a times y
it's not a function of T but Matlab
expects it it could be a function of T
so I have to specify that it could be a
function of T even if it's not and it
returns a times y so this is the ode
fund here
I put in the time span T and I put in my
initial condition y naught so that's all
that this needs I could have defined a
function you know in a new file you know
my right hand side or my ode right hand
side you know equals a times y this is
just the quick and dirty way to do it in
Matlab using function handles okay
that's called a function handle and I'm
pretty sure if I run this it'll be fine
and now I'm going to plot T by y
um
and you know Y is now this Vector so I
only want to plot the first component
the position component it has a velocity
component I'm only going to plot the
position components uh uh and I'll plot
it in a different color also line with
two
okay and I'll put in a legend now the
first one is my analytic
and the second one is my ode 45 solution
okay
and you can see the dashed line and the
solid line they're perfectly on top of
each other meaning that this od45
numerical integrator did a really good
job of capturing the analytic solution
that we derived from scratch with uh
with pencil and paper or on this this
light board okay so really easy to work
these things out
um you know in Matlab or in Python it's
only a few lines uh you can do it you
know if you have the solution by hand
you can just plot it if not you can
integrate it analytically using this
ode45 function
in Python it's really um almost
identical okay so you have to do some
more explicit importing you have to
import numpy and some plotting tools and
you have to integrate this in you have
to import scipies integrate
functionality this is kind of the ode45
uh in in Python is this solve ivp and
then
um same thing we're creating a Time
Vector which is just you know linear
um time Vector uh I guess
I guess we're going to divide by delta T
at some point probably we'll see there's
our same initial condition our same
analytic solution here that you can plot
you can build the same a matrix that we
did before and create this little
ode that Returns the right hand side so
this is just like what my function
handle in Matlab was doing this is
returning the right hand side kind of
the what d d y d t equals is a times y
That's My linear ode and then solve ivp
this is the same as as ode45 it takes in
that function handle that right hand
side Vector field that we're integrating
a time span an initial condition and
which times to evaluate on and then you
can plot everything the same and the
plot's going to look exactly the same
you know you see here kind of again our
analytic and fourth order won't get cut
up perfectly match each other uh on this
this time span
he's by hand by you know solving this
characteristic polynomial by guessing e
to the Lambda T and solving this
characteristic polynomial or you can
write it as a system of first order
equations and solve for the eigenvalues
of a that's also going to help you out
here and you can plot these things in uh
you can solve these and plot these in
python or Matlab and very importantly if
you confirm the eigenvalues of this a
matrix are in fact the roots of my pair
my my characteristic polynomial okay I'm
going to erase this I'm going to shut
this down and then I'll just give you
two more super quick and dirty examples
of these just so you see how it works if
I change the coefficients a little bit
so hold tight
okay uh so just a couple more super
super quick examples I'm going to fly
through these because we know the
formula now uh what if we have X double
dot instead of plus 3x dot we have minus
three x dot plus two x equals zero so
all we're changing is the sign here and
let's keep our same initial or some
other initial conditions x 0 equals two
x dot zero equals three those are our
initial conditions we're going to solve
this exactly how we did before so I'm
going to write down my characteristic
polynomial and here's a trick you can
just write down the characteristic
polynomial when it's in this form the
characteristic polynomial are literally
going to have the same coefficients as
the coefficients of these terms so I'm
going to get 1 times Lambda squared
minus three
times Lambda plus 2
and that equals zero that's my
characteristic polynomial I'll just show
you uh you know if I assumed x equals e
to the Lambda t x dot equals Lambda e to
the Lambda t x double dot equals Lambda
squared e to the Lambda T and I plug
these in
of course I'm going to get
Lambda squared everything's going to
have an e to the Lambda T so I'm just
going to pull that out already so my X
double Dot's going to have a Lambda
squared
my X Dot's going to have a minus 3
Lambda minus 3 Lambda and my 2x is going
to have a plus two all of them times e
to the Lambda T equals zero and so of
course my characteristic polynomial just
is has the same coefficients as as my
ode and so we can solve this thing
really easily
um let's make sure I don't botch this so
this is Lambda now minus 2 times Lambda
minus 1 equals zero and so before it was
Lambda plus two and Lambda plus one and
so now my eigenvalues are Lambda equals
one
and Lambda equals two and I should be
worried right now because anytime I have
a positive Lambda I'm going to get a
positive e to the Lambda T and that's
going to blow up to Infinity that's
going to blow up to positive Infinity as
time goes on so this is an unstable
system I can already feel it and I'm
pretty sure that my coefficients are
going to be one and one because I picked
it this is you know you can just pause
the video and convince yourself you know
X of t
equals e to the Lambda 1T
plus e to the Lambda 2T
you can convince yourself that this
satisfies those initial conditions
that's a good exercise for you to do but
this is the solution
and this solution the other solution
damped out to zero it decayed to zero in
finite time we plotted it we showed it
because these were negative values so e
to the minus t decays to zero but e to
the plus T any to the plus two t these
grow without bound these grow uh
unbounded there's no bound to how much
these grow these grow unbounded in time
and the word we use for that is we call
this unstable it's un sometimes I feel
unstable these are unstable Solutions
these are unstable eigenvalues okay and
we're going to come back to that later
but so you know just changing this sign
here and making these eigenvalues
positive means that now I have e to the
positive lambdas and these grow without
bound good good unstable Solutions
literally meaning X goes to Infinity
as T goes to Infinity okay
one more example I'm going to erase do
the same thing actually do I need to
erase I don't I'm just going to do it
right here
let's do one more example X double dot
Plus
x dot minus 2X
I'm just checking my notes because I've
carefully crafted these coefficients to
be really easy for me
uh X naught is going to equal three
x dot naught is going to equal
zero
okay again we're just going to read off
our characteristic polynomial here maybe
I'll do it in green our characteristic
polynomial is Lambda squared plus Lambda
minus 2 equals zero and so I can Factor
this thing into uh Lambda
plus two
times Lambda minus 1. does that work
Lambda squared plus 2 Lambda minus
Lambda is a positive Lambda minus two
that works equals zero
that means Lambda equals plus one and
Lambda equals minus two are solutions
again I can write down X of T equals
some constant e to this Lambda t plus
another constant e to this Lambda
T that's a solution I'm pretty sure
uh based on these initial conditions we
can find that C1 is 2 and C2 is one so
this equals two e to the T
plus e to the minus 2T this is a good
exercise for you just pause and convince
yourself that these coefficients satisfy
this initial data these initial
conditions and now what happens here so
this is why I chose this example for the
last one this one has a negative Lambda
this is going to decay in time this one
has a positive this is literally my
solution in time this one has a positive
Lambda this one is going to grow
unbounded unstable in time
now if I add up something that decays to
zero and something that blows up to
Infinity obviously this one wins and so
the system is still unstable
so having even one one positive
eigenvalue or one positive Lambda even
if I add you know multiple of these the
system is still going to be unstable
okay so that's really important also
okay good one
I want you to do is for both of these
examples
um
I want you to write down this the first
order uh the coupled system of first
order equations The Matrix system
version of these I want you to compute
the eigenvalues and convince yourself
that those eigenvalues are exactly the
same as these lambdas okay that's the
last thing I want you to do all right
next we're going to show what we you
know how we get higher order
differential equations with like
quadruple dots or you know Tuple dots
like more dots more derivatives and then
how to handle those in exactly the same
way and we're going to build up to
General Matrix Systems and general
eigenvalues and eigenvectors we'll be
able to solve every single possible
linear system very soon stay tuned thank
you
[Music]
foreign